Stephanie's an economist from MIT and
she started this company called a pretty
group and she's going to talk about
blockchain and economics thank you
everybody
yes as you can tell I'm not Nils
I hope the Facebook emergency is okay so
I'm gonna be talking about blockchain
get blockchain and economics today from
an extremely applied perspective and in
a second you'll see why
so as obby said I'm a founding economist
of a company called prism group we came
together about two years ago as
blockchain entered the mainstream
because we're peach the economists I did
my PhD in an area called market design
at Harvard and we realized there was
going to be an opportunity for a lot of
really interesting economic design and
so we wanted to come together and form a
a group that worked with blockchain
projects to think about the design of
the different components that that
touched on a lot of economics that we
knew so we do a combination of advising
research consulting really sort of
translational stuff hopefully this will
be the last sort of salesy thing you see
today
and so what excited us and the reason we
left academia left you know our previous
jobs and decided to start prism group
it's because watching projects are
rethinking how economies are designed
right and I know that there's a wide
variety of familiarity with economics in
the audience so this is a more you know
broad level talk but blockchain projects
especially permission this ones on a
daily basis are thinking about how can
we use currency how can we design
incentives how can we design
marketplaces in new and interesting and
more decentralized ways and there's lots
of really great opportunities to apply
tools from economics to try to make
these systems work you know in more
traditional settings you know it's
typically quite difficult to have an
opportunity to redesign a whole market
you typically have to convince a whole
lot of people if you want to redesign a
multi-million dollar spectrum auction or
a school matching mechanism which I'll
talk about later takes a lot of years
you
usually got to be quite advanced and you
know you only get one shot so the the
chance to see so many iterations on how
economic systems could be designed and
redesigned was an opportunity that was
too good to pass up and there are a lot
of different definitions of you know
what is economics
obviously there's micro and macro and
subfields of both so what we think about
is we come at this from a more micro
economic point of view which is that
economics is thinking about how
individuals make decisions right if you
go and take a first economics class you
talk about you know rational decision
making under constraints you take
another one you talk about behavioral
issues but the idea is that there's
systematic patterns and how people make
decisions people can be strategic how
are they going to interact with the
platform that you're building how are
they going to choose the you to use the
tools you're making and once they make
those decisions are you gonna be happy
with the outcome is the platform founder
right
so one of the most again interesting
parts of working on an economic design
and blockchain is getting to bring
together different aspects of economics
and so this is what we lovingly call our
house right so when we first started
thinking deeply about design we were
like okay well you know my business
partner did her PhD in contract design I
did mine in market design you know
information systems and you know there's
whole nobel prizes on the role of
information in markets how do we bring
this together into a unified framework
so we think about this in terms of
layers right so obviously you know if
you're a business and you're building
something I blockchain we hope you've
got you know some kind of you know value
proposition you've raised some capital a
year ago this was you know you had an
ICO maybe not so much anymore and then
you start to build the different layers
of you know incentives and and
mechanisms that shape incentives so
thinking about you know how do we design
a contract interaction between two
people you're buying and selling
something what if the contract look like
is there dispute resolution do you have
an escrow system set up stepping back
you know what is the marketplace look
like do you have search and matching do
you how is your pricing do you actually
need an auction if you're gonna have one
on your platform what information
mechanisms does the platform you to
provide and then how does the token and
the governance interact with that right
so you know as we've learned just
inventing a token out of thin air so
sometimes a bad idea a token if there's
a native token it needs to have a
purpose it should interact with the
economics of the rest of the system and
governance is I'll talk about a little
bit later is how you know thinking about
how a decentralized system can can
evolve over time
so I wanted I'm gonna spend most of the
time talking about a field called what
we call economic design comes mostly
from an area of economics called market
design that many of you may be familiar
with but I wanted to start out just by
reflecting on the progress that's been
made in thinking about economic design
in blockchain over the past year right
so as I was putting this together I came
across a presentation I did about a year
ago talking about sort of what do we
think are the biggest issues in economic
design applied to blockchain and
blockchain projects and the four that we
saw a year ago were were the following
so the first was the idea that tokens
are incentives right you have a complex
incentive design problem we're gonna
create a native token it's going to
solve our problem and work for sort of
the second fallacy was the idea that
economics was not useful for botching
and we saw this especially for projects
that had started sort of before the boom
this was not relevant there was a sort
of a quest for a universal mechanism and
then forth and this is relates to the
talk that Primavera gave earlier today
was the idea of governance and do we
need governance and how much governance
do we need
um so do any of you remember token
curated registries so these were again
something that we saw more of probably
at the end of 2018 but a token curated
registry was basically a way of coming
up with a decentralized mechanism for
curating a list and the idea was that we
didn't want the New York Times to have
power to decide the best restaurants in
New York or Jonathan Gold's have power
to decide the best restaurants in Los
Angeles we're gonna set up a
decentralized mechanism facilitated by a
token that's going to do this curation
for us and I won't go through all the
steps but this is my stylized diagram of
how token curated registries work and
the basic idea was that there was this
very complex and interesting multi-party
market incentive design problem that's
hard and the TCR way was basically just
to say like here's a native token and
everyone's gonna have to use it and this
will automatically align the sentence of
the system these typically didn't work
out very well they sort of gone away but
this general idea that you can just use
tokens to align incentives is something
that we've really seen dissipate over
the past 12 months the second piece is
this is what I like to call the
blockchain rebel this is one of my
favorite guys so he loves Bitcoin and
he's in a desert and there's this idea
that other areas of expertise were not
applicable to to blockchain based
projects it's also something that we've
really seen evolution on and sort of an
interaction with other areas another
thing that we've I've seen sort of move
on in the past 12 months is what I used
to call the borrowed suit so in
conversation with the blockchain project
you say okay you really need economic
design and the response would be okay
who do we go copy it from and for many
of you for those of you who do mechanism
and market design it's highly customized
it's highly specific to the environment
and if you just copy and paste you end
up you know looking like our friend here
wearing his dad's suit
and something that doesn't really work
well for your specific setting I mean
finally something that we've seen less
of lately is what I called forking is
freedom you could also call it
governance let's wing it but this idea
that formal governance or formal
decision-making procedures for
collective we're not necessary right and
if people can't agree on what they want
to do we're just gonna keep working
until everyone's on their own individual
blockchain and you know so again these
are stylized but you know just
reflecting now these are really topics
that you don't see as much of a
discussion of anymore so you know first
I've seen a reckoning that there's no
real free lunch in in issuing tokens
right if you issue a token and you sell
it the people who are still holding it
are gonna want it to have some value
that comes from somewhere and many times
in order to have a token that has value
you need to have created investment
right you either need it to have you
know expensive collateral that's
attached to your stable corn or you need
to have invested in the ecosystem that
the token is facilitating so that people
actually want to come and buy and use it
and these things are expensive it's
difficult to just mint a token and put
it out into the world and have it be
worth things second we see proactive
governance design as a part of platform
design so this is something that came up
this morning a lot of platforms are
thinking about on chain governance as
just another part of their system design
the third is starting to see more
insightful outside in academic research
and what I call outside in is you know
people using publicly available data
thinking about mining pools which we
just saw thinking about transactions on
Bitcoin and other publicly available
blockchain so I'm using what we now have
is a very nice time series combined with
economic insights to you know help think
about how these markets work just as one
example for those of you who were at I
called it CSC but I guess it's desk
two weeks ago San Francisco blockchain
week there's a convert
put on by blockchain at Berkeley and
there was an economics Trek that we put
together one of the presenters is
actually from has a professor named
Christine parlor who studies finance and
she was looking at something called
price discrimination in a Bitcoin
transaction processing so her thesis was
basically that miners were leaving
blocks a little bit empty so that they
could reject low-paying transactions and
forced people to pay more and this is
actually you know really big this goes
against sort of the lot of the
prevailing literature and is a really
you know if true is a very sort of
interesting and fundamental shift in how
we think about minor behavior so I kind
of sat there was like whoa this is great
and then finally of course as we see
from this room and lots of other venues
we see more interactions not only with
game theorists and economists but
lawyers and psychologists and
sociologists and you know you see more
and more of these interactions as well
as with with startups
so I want to actually spend the rest of
the time talking about what you could
call economic design market design I'm
sure some of you are very familiar with
this but I'm going to assume sort of a
base of you know start from the
beginning so there's a set of economists
who think about how do you decide him
how do you study and design markets so
that they work well one of them is al
Roth who's at Stanford he was one of my
PhD advisors and his basic insight that
he's really you know moved he and a
group of eminent economists have really
started to think about how it was an
economist act like an engineer right you
can't just bring your theoretical
insights you know the the analogy that
gets used a lot is the difference
between physics and engineering when
you're building a bridge right physics
is great but when you're building the
when you're actually building the bridge
you have to think about the mud and the
rocks and all the details of the
particular landscape that you're
building on and incorporate them into so
how do we think about a very similar
kind of approach for economic design of
of a variety of environments
and this approach I'll talk a little bit
more about sort of the framework for it
it turns out there have been a number of
large economic design instances that are
going to win a lot of people a lot of
Nobel Prizes that followed very similar
sort of approaches to design they were
in very different environments but they
followed a similar technique and they're
really interesting so one of them is the
auction of broadband spectrum this was
in the late 90s is is anyone familiar
with the spectrum auctions obvious
anybody else okay yeah you've heard
about them so in the late 90s the I
think it was the FCC realized that their
method for allocating broadband spectrum
was not working they used to have it by
petitions or sort of the first system
was you could have you know petition and
say this is why I need the spectrum that
was taking too long and then they tried
a lottery the thing was anybody could
enter the lottery so one of the big
blocks of spectrum in Boston went to a
group of lawyers who just entered the
lottery and we're like or not lawyers
dentists who were like hey let's see if
we can win some spectrum and they got
some spectrum it's that was a terrible
idea so a group of economists from
Caltech and from Stanford and from
University of Western Ontario were
brought in to think about how do we
design this very complex combinatorial
auction and they started from scratch
you know they thought about other
auctions they thought about you know
what experiments can we run I'll talk
about this a little bit more later but
they ended up designing an auction
that's been used for I think the
aggregate total overall applications is
like a hundred billion dollars worth of
allocation problems and this was an
environment where there had not been an
auction like this design before right
the economists were brought in and they
were like okay you're gonna design this
and launch it you've got one shot tell
us what to do another example where you
know economic design has come up this is
Professor Roth's work with numerous
people at Stanford is the medical
residency match anybody married to a med
student friends with med student there
you go
those of you who aren't familiar with
the US medical system when you finish
medical school in the US your first job
is called a residency and the you
actually don't get it through a free
labor market you go through a
centralized matching mechanism so you go
through a period of round of
applications you go through a round of
interviews and then everybody submits
rank order lists and an elaborate
version of Galle Shapley algorithm is
used to match people and jobs so you're
a doctor you're coming up on your final
year of med school you get an envelope
in the mail you rip it open it tells you
where you're moving and he needed to be
redesigned again in the late 90s because
it turns out that medical students we're
all getting married to each other but
you couldn't enter the match together so
there were a lot of really unhappy
married couples so they redesigned it so
you could enter as a married pair and
this similar actually a very similar
algorithm with a lot of sort of
engineering tweaks is applied to assign
k-12 students to schools in New York and
Boston and after the success of the
residency match they asked the same team
to come in and think about centralized
mechanisms for assigning students to
schools ended up using something very
similar to Gale Shapley with a lot of
tweaks again because this is a these are
different environments and so what is
yeah
it's a really good question especially
if you talk to recent doctors who have
gone through it they don't love it
there's people have looked at matches
that unravel basically like you hadn't
matched and then you didn't and they're
fewer doctors got jobs there were sort
of more empty openings and people who
were really good ended up at lower
matched institutions so basically what
you get is you go from having a national
market to a whole bunch of little mini
markets and so there are efficiency
gains from being able to have a national
market without the match you're
basically looking for a job on the
weekends so you're kind of looking
around your medical school so it's
basically being able to pull together a
national network that's not to say
everybody loves it but there is there is
efficiency very similar with school
matching when the New York City schools
called up the team that did this the
reason they were looking for a new
mechanism is that a third of students
every year were not matched to schools
so they go through the school matching
process as it was and you'd have a third
of students where they're just like no
outcome for you and so one of the
benefits of the revised mechanism is
that students get matched and you know
there's sort of metrics like that you
don't have to gain the system you kind
of if you play honestly and just blank
yours
to be ranked first by the students oh
maybe
yeah that's there is it's interesting
sort of how everybody learns loopholes
in mechanisms but one of the efforts
especially in Boston was to make the
matching mechanism strategy proof
especially for the the families they
didn't want anybody have to think about
you know strategic ordering but ya know
reading about New York City public
schools always gives me the shivers
so just to recap you know if you look at
these different stories these were done
by different teams they happen to be
done at similar time sort of in the late
90s and early 2000s and they followed a
very similar paradigm for thinking about
how do you design a mechanism for
thousands of people or millions of
dollars that's going to get launched and
has never been used before there's a
very similar pattern that all of these
projects followed so the first is to
draw upon economic and game theory right
what do we know what models can we use
where can we start thinking about
different categories of mechanisms and
the different parameters we want to
think about changing second is what
observational evidence do we have right
so what existing markets look like this
where have we seen auctions that you
know have we come is there something we
could take from timber auctions to think
about spectrum auctions what can we put
together based on observational pieces
the third piece is going into the lab so
the spectrum auction team actually was
this was very interesting so once they
had sort of families of models that they
were thinking of implementing they
partnered with Charlie plot who is a
Caltech who's an experimental economist
and they just ran horse races they said
ok these they had a well-defined sort of
list of goals that they wanted to pursue
and they kept running experiments and
seeing which auction mechanisms were
getting them closest to what they wanted
one of the things that some of my
favorite things about this story is that
professor plot is also an accomplished
auction designer and he actually ended
up knocking out one of his own models
which is sort of in I think is a very
good testament to the scientific nature
of the process and then finally rolling
this out and sometimes you'll see
smaller scale lab experiment or field
experiments so for example for the
spectrum auction after the lab
experiments were done and they had their
sort of main candidate design they
didn't just go and redesign a 10 billion
dollar market they carved off a small
segment of the market which was the
pager bandwidth and they just ran like a
little two-day auction with a simplified
version and said ok you know let's see
if this works it works fine ok let's
let's go out and make sure this happens
you design basically little mini toy
experiments it's typically you know
undergrads so I think this case this was
actually interesting because they were
doing it and it was Caltech undergrads
so they would come in and you know break
the mechanism or find some super crazy
way to game it so that typically goes
more in the lab section you can actually
get a good amount from one thing you'll
get a lot from lab experiments is
finding out that the mechanism you've
designed it's too complicated right so
you present it to the lab agents and
they're just like what on earth what is
this like we don't know how to interact
with it it would take a lot of time and
investment but I agree sort of if you're
thinking about getting things that are
the right magnitude for people to care
about it you're thinking more about lab
field experiments I agree with that so
to keep going because this is you know
about blockchain this is not about
school matching I think that you know
the reason I wanted to talk about this
and sort of talk about this framework is
that we've gotten to the point from my
point of view in thinking about applied
economic design and blockchain that
we've moved past sort of the first-order
things I talked about that you saw more
a year ago you know magical tokens and
anarchy and freedom you know unlimited
and a complete lack of design and we
moved into a stage where there's really
opportunities for taking this approach
to economic design and thinking about it
in a blockchain setting and so this is
what I want to talk about sort of for
the rest of the the talk and this is you
know these are some categories of things
that we see across projects that there's
really more work to be done in digging
in and thinking about the specifics of
how to engineer systems so that they
work well and so the three are first the
practical design of performance
incentives right so I'll talk about in
more detail but this is but sort of you
know in many blockchain based systems
you're thinking about how do you
incentivize people to
do what you need them to do to
contribute resources to the network to
participate in governance and you're
going to give them a reward in exchange
for doing a specific behavior turns out
that the design of incentives like that
is tremendously difficult and I'll talk
about that more later the second is the
adoption of what I'll comb market
infrastructure but thinking about the
invisible levers of market design that
make the markets we use every day
function well and thinking about how
they could translate into a blockchain
setting and then the third and this is
again related to things we've seen today
is thinking about sort of how much
governance do we need and sort of there
I'll discuss a little further we've
moved a lot on sort of how much
governance do we see in platforms and
now we're thinking about how do we
design governance that's the right
amount of participation but doesn't
overwhelm the participants so first a
little bit about performance incentives
so I would love your thoughts on this
one I'm done all lawyers like one thing
is we think about a week think about
governance from a very economists point
of view and I love having lawyers and
law professors in the audience because
you guys have a ton of context so we
loved out you'll see the economic
version I'd love to see that absolutely
so first in terms of performance
incentives this is one of my favorite
this is the Wells Fargo account scandal
do people remember this
so Wells Fargo was trying to figure out
how do they increase revenue and so they
decided that what they were going to do
was pay their employees based on the
number of accounts that the employees
opened because they believe that if
employees open more accounts they would
have more revenue and then it turns out
what the employees did was they just
opened a ton of fake accounts right so
there was this implicit belief in the
management I don't know what was going
on in their brains but basically that
there was this correlation between the
number of counts that were opened and
the business that the bank did and if
they pulled on this one lever they
would get a positive response in the
leopard that they actually cared about
which was the amount of business a lot
of people are going to prison I believe
over over this so you know incentive
design is also really important for
decentralized systems one thing that we
think a lot about is the relationship
between the incentive design for minors
and the level of distribution of control
right so if you think about what were
some of the original objectives of
Bitcoin mining you know you wanted the
protocol to be widely adopted peer to
peer to be secure and to have
distributed control right and for three
of these four criteria there's actually
been a great deal of success but as we
saw in the previous talk there is a
probably more consolidation than he she
or they would have preferred in the
current design and this is actually an
incentive issue this is thinking about
you know what are the incentives to
invest and and how do they shape the
incentives for consolidation versus
versus separation and so I think one of
the challenges we see is that again
designing well-functioning performance
incentives is extremely difficult
figuring out how to compensate people
what to compensate them for so that they
do the activity that you want them to do
when not something random that's not
actually what you want is quite
challenging but especially when you
don't have centralized control right
when you have a distributed system
without somebody in charge this is
extremely important because this is how
you're going to motivate people to
contribute resources or participate in
governance or whatever else you want so
these are some of the issues that can
come up in designing performance
incentives I won't go through them in
detail but one of the challenges we do
see is especially as platforms grow and
they get wider adoption there is going
to be interaction with strategic agents
right so a question we get a lot is you
know what many platforms start out with
a highly committed set of almost
altruistic actors right so they really
love your platform and they're very
excited about the product and maybe
they're willing to my
even if it isn't profitable at the
moment and so to what extent can you
count on that kind of participation
versus thinking about profit maximizing
actors and how does this change as the
platform grows
and this has actually been a challenge
so one platform that has had some public
issues and I am NOT meaning to to rip on
storage I think it's awesome that they
have discussed this in public and this
is why we use this so storage launched
their a decentralized storage as their
name says decentralized storage and it
turns out that there were some money
pumps in their incentive design so you
could make money by being a person who
stored files and had files stored and
you just passed files back and forth to
each other and you could make quite a
bit of money and then the question was
during this process will people find
these money pumps and it turns out the
answer is yes right so you know
understanding that there's gonna be a
set of individuals who are going to be
profit maximizing and who will find the
money pumps on your platform is
something that I think is is difficult
in the design process
so I mean the money pump is it
essentially it's a wealth transfer right
from investors of the store network to
the miners or I mean there's no
efficiency gain so clearly like the
money pump like work where does the
money come from it's not like they're
building more tractors because of
storage and therefore having more
resources to share right so it was I
think in that particular case it was
whoever had bought the token right the I
think at that they were actually getting
money from the from the from the
platform itself so the platform was
served paying subsidies and they but the
I think the the platform intended this
Treasury to be used for productive
activity and this was not productive
activity and just the last piece is
thinking about you know as we design
incentives a lot of the times we we
focus on you know I'm going to do this
in the contract and then you're gonna
pay me for it and that's it but there's
actually different levers that you can
use to design incentive systems and so
it's not just formal contracts or smart
contracts but something called a
relational contract which is basically
that if I behave well with you you will
give me future business right and so
this is something that we use quite
often when our formal contracts are not
not really
there's not really a metric for what we
want so you know for example a lot of
professional services firms actually
survive on relational contracts if you
ever work in management consulting it's
all relational contracts um and then
also thinking about the role of
reputation and how well designed
reputation mechanisms can incentivize
good behavior because if you behave
poorly everybody's gonna know about it
the second piece I wanted to talk about
is the introduction of market mechanisms
and thinking about what are the market
institutions yeah so I can give you a
really great non blockchain example eBay
does these fantastically for those of
you who know steep to Delos it has he
was involved in this he's a amazing
economist so if you think about eBay's
is he big ok talk about eBay does that
work for the example okay yeah no no
I'll go through it yep so fractured
people who have used eBay eBay is a
great example they have great market
design and you can see all of it
let me see okay so this is another piece
of eBay I have pictures from eBay we're
going ahead oh I got rid of that one
sorry so eBay is a peer-to-peer sales
platform so if I have an antique teacup
and I want to sell it I go on eBay and
they say one antique teacup Pasadena and
you go online you're like oh there's the
antique tea cutter I want I'm in Boston
you can either use an auction mechanism
or a Buy It Now mechanism to agree on a
price you have a certain amount I have a
certain amount of time to mail it to you
we pay via PayPal or whatever mechanism
you want so it's a peer-to-peer market
with a huge variety of stuff on it right
heterogeneous good so modulus Goods and
there's a lot of you know that's been
written about it and so the key here is
that it is an eBay's best interest that
the buyers and the sellers who show up
to the platform behave in good faith
right if you know that everybody on eBay
is selling stuff that doesn't actually
look like the picture and I know that
you're never going to send me anything
no one's gonna use eBay right so they
have a variety of incentive mechanisms
to
incentivize truthful participation so of
course there's a contract right like I
will send you this and there's I'll talk
about dispute resolution but there's
dispute resolution which basically says
you know one of us has violated the
explicit contract that we had to buy and
sell something you may help
there's also relational contracting so
an example of this that comes up is
thinking about the relationship between
so the the platform actually mediates
this so another way if you're a bad
seller that they'll punish you is
they'll actually negatively weight you
in the search algorithm so the next time
somebody comes and they're like teacup
if I've been terrible I get plummeted to
the bottom you'll never find me and then
the third one is they have a star rating
system so you sort of layer all of these
together yeah it's an interesting
question
a traditional relational contract is
just a bilateral relationship so you
could think about if you needed to buy I
mean eBay is not a great example for
relational contracts unless you just buy
a tea cup every week right you could
think about if if Abby's trying to build
up his set of do you collect something
in particular I'll just keep using tea
tops
unless you have another preference you
know it scarves if you wanted you know
if I'm a great vendor of scarves and you
want to buy a scarf every month you
might come back to me there are models
that think about
yeah and so there is there's interesting
research thinking about sort of when do
you go from relational contracts to
reputation it sort of you good bigger
and bigger networks so the second piece
and we've touched on this I'll go
quickly through is thinking about market
mechanisms so again coming from the
ethos of forking is freedom there can be
a hesitancy to use market design
mechanisms to help markets function well
but they can actually have a very useful
purpose so one of them is dispute
resolution so again if I don't send a be
his tea cup he can go here and he can
say I haven't received my tea cup and
eBay will intervene and make me send it
or make me give you a refund and kicked
me off the platform and do all sorts of
good stuff so this builds trust within
the platform itself there's a blockchain
based competitor to eBay called open
Bazaar and they actually launched and
they specifically said we're not going
to have intermediation we're just going
to let you buy and sell they had almost
nothing I think you even get to pick
what search engine you use on open
Bazaar and very very quickly they found
they needed dispute resolution because
no one's gonna use a peer-to-peer sales
platform without it so they have a
market for dispute arbitrators know many
of you are familiar with sort of
thinking about the different mechanisms
that can be used to match people in
markets I won't go into Netflix because
it's not quite a it's not a two sided
market it's a one sided market but
thinking about how do you use choice
data to give people what they want in a
very crowded market with lots of goods
another piece I think is really
interesting again this is Steve to
Dallas at Hawes with Chris nasco
redesigned the eBay reputation mechanism
so basically if you look at the star
rating on eBay for sellers it turns out
the distribution of it looks like this
this is from 0 to 1 this is 0.96 and
this is 1 so this star rating that you
were using for information about sellers
it turns out it contained no information
at all and the reason was
so the way this was computed I think
this was the fraction of positive
feedback over the fraction of positive
and negative feedback and they found
that the reason was that if you did
leave some one negative feedback there's
a good chance you get threatened so
people would leave you nasty voicemail
they would threaten your safety people
were calling the police and so if you
didn't like your experience you wouldn't
leave negative feedback you just
wouldn't say anything and so what they
ended up doing was creating a metric
where they said if your rating is the
ratio of positive feedback to everybody
you've dealt with and then the other
piece which I think is just really cool
is they realize that if they rolled it
out to sellers if they announce that
this is what they were using everyone
would just game that right you just
start getting voicemails that we're like
you didn't leave me any feedback why
didn't you leave me any feedback leave
me feedback so instead of rolling this
out and announcing it they just baked it
into this search algorithm so they
started ranking search results using
this but they didn't tell anybody and so
they found this was much more truthful
if you look at the distribution it's a
nice even distribution of feedback they
found it
what's correlated with quality and so so
yeah you know this is still there so I
think the assumption is that no is
really going to leave negative feedback
and we're gonna take this into account
and ya know I think if you bae users
start reading a you know counter metric
of papers then we might have a problem
and so you know what is the point of
this a lot of this these are not talking
about blockchain based examples but as
we think about you know what are a lot
of the applications that people use to
you know hope to use blockchain for a
huge one is data marketplaces we've
worked with a lot of data marketplaces
many of them think that there's no
infrastructure required right we're
gonna launch the marketplace people can
come and buy and sell data and we don't
want to intermediate right and so
thinking about what do we already know
from eBay and other places and how can
we use them to maximize the probability
that you know you BDI or this was a
Oda's data marketplace they have a
really nice graphic does anybody know if
they've launched
last I heard they this is the iota I'd
say they've improved it I would say
they've they've added useful data to the
marketplace right so the previous rating
was useless now they have more
information that they can use how it
evolves over time I think is a is an
interesting question I mean it's related
to the question of what happens when the
parents in New York City figure out how
to game the school match right but no
it's a good point
I don't know how email marketing works
so so so the final piece I want to talk
about for what do I have five minutes
ten minutes okay ISM is blotching
governance and this is a piece that I
think we've had there's been more
experimentation so we have a little bit
more data on this specifically in a in a
botching setting so what is governance
just to start out this is again the
economics definition happy to talk with
lawyers and others who think about this
a lot so we separate we tend to think of
governance as separate from operations
so operations is the rules and processes
for the day-to-day this is what's
programmed into your protocol more or
less well-defined legal processes things
like this governance is the process by
which you make decisions that are not
part of the operations right so we
talked a little bit about the dow hack
earlier today that's an example where
governance was very useful another one
that I actually like is when
kiddies launched and it completely
clogged aetherium this was result in two
ways so first they the miners got
together and increased the network gas
limit but then they also modified they
put a button that allowed you to
resubmit your transactions with a higher
gas price and so this is an example
where you know you might need governance
in a positive situation to it's not
always that your platforms in a downward
spiral this is like yeah I think this is
more like let's wing a governance but
it's a it's a lot of examples you hear
of governance tend to be like negative
crises and so I like this one because
this is sort of adoption exceeded our
greatest hopes now how do we expand
quicker than we thought so so
unfortunately you can't eliminate the
need for governance there is an area of
economics called the economics of
incomplete contracts which basically
says that there's no way to write a
contract that's going to perfectly
anticipate everything that could
possibly happen there's always going to
be a chance that either something's not
specified or you need to renegotiate the
contract and therefore you're going to
need governance and so in a bot chain
setting when do you need governance you
need to either when the system is
working but we want to upgrade maybe we
need to you know change the gas limit or
the system is in crisis and we need to
figure out what we're going to do
and this is also related to the talk
earlier one thing we talk about is
there's really not in absence of
governance right if there's a crisis
someone who's going to step up and solve
it the question is is it going to be the
person who has the following or the you
know loudest screaming voice is a good
be neither is it going to be the person
or people that you've delegated
designated ahead of time because you
want them to be making the decision so
ignoring governance doesn't mean it goes
away it just means that you're you know
who knows and one thing I did think was
interesting was I hadn't thought before
that that might actually have some some
legal benefit I think that's an
interesting point so we think about the
different elements these are the
economic elements of governance and one
thing that comes up a lot is thinking
about who the stakeholders and the
governance process should be so after
the need for governance was recognized
there was a movement towards what you
could call referendum based governance
which is every decision gets made by
everybody
maybe it's weighted by stake but we're
gonna put every decision out to the
community and have people vote and it
turns out when you do that the
participation in voting is extremely low
right so this is a collection of data
from foreground capital looking at
participation and in different on chain
governance votes there's some higher
participation here but you get lots of
participation below 10% and so one
question that we see platforms thinking
about is the role of representative
governance right how much
decentralization do we need what are the
decisions that we know the entire
community wants to be involved with and
which ones benefit from division of
labor right we use division of labor in
the governance of our countries right I
mean in California we have referendum
based governance which is interesting
but at least at the federal level we
have professional legislators right and
this also allows for a degree of
specialization and so I think many
projects we talked to or think about you
know what is the representative nature
what decisions do they make what goes
out to the full group and how
comfortable are we with introducing that
additional layer of centralization so
that's actually where I'm going to those
are sort of the three areas I see for
economic design I anticipate we'll see a
lot of progress over the next 12 months
one question that I want to leave open
that I found you know there's a lot of
I've talked a lot about sort of how
economics from other areas can be
beneficial for blockchain one thing I
found really interesting to think about
taking from blockchain and moving back
into economics is thinking about the
economic role of the firm
so economics has a concept of a firm it
has economic purposes depending on who
you talk to they're different there's
usually about four but if you think
about how do we take a centralized
system and get rid of the central
authority you find out that firms have a
huge number of roles in our day to day
activities you know their crisis
decision-making your
management-by-exception they set up
incentives they do a whole variety of
things that don't always get credit in
the economic literature but it turns out
a really important and so going through
and realizing sort of what are each of
the different elements that we use we're
used to having firms take care of and
can they be replicated in a more
decentralized way is an interesting
ongoing project anyway that's the
content I've got for you guys here's my
contact information and happy to take
questions or comments or thoughts first
you you have this your last question
there was on the economic piece of the
firm I guess I just wanted to kind of
give a slightly an another example
you might use to think about that as
it's like it seems to me like trying to
imagine before hand building Linux by a
company would be really tough actually
it's kind of centralized so it's what
would I guess say there's lots of I
think was built out of companies at AT&T
it was built in the basement on two
person's own time because they won't
play video games so I wouldn't say it
was built by a company and Lee that's
that's totally different
well so I guess what I'm hearing is
you're pushing back on the idea that
there are open source projects that are
a different example that's a better one
I'm just saying that that particular
example doesn't ok so there's lots of
open source projects sir you can maybe
you can pick your favorite one I I'm
happy for you to pick your favorite open
source project and it seems like there
are lots of economic things that that's
happening for those and we might think
about how they compare with
[Music]
decentralized I mean no that's it's not
easy to compare them to a firm I had
another comment earlier you you were
talking about you said that these were
on macro your earth coming from a micro
perspective and I just I guess you're
talking about governance and what will
try to end there there's lots of things
that seem to go beyond like the normal
micro perspective it seems
I don't I just wondered if you had a
comment on you know like the impact of
law
you know big things beyond micro it's
this is what are you going beyond micro
there so anything yeah so two things I
think the the open source software
example is very interesting one thing I
think that's interesting about Linux I'm
not an expert is that you know Linux was
you know invented I guess in a
decentralized way they had a very strong
leader in Linus Torvalds and then I
think the example of Red Hat the company
is very interesting because they tried
to take Linux and turn it into something
that was eventually purchased by IBM so
sort of the reverse buy agree with you
that those examples are interesting in
terms of the macro versus micro
economics and that was more a comment if
you go and study traditional
macroeconomics like you know you'd go
work and monetary policy at the Fed it's
traditionally not based on models of
individual agent choice it's the kind of
thing where you're like GDP is equal to
G you know and haven't done this in so
long but like consumption plus
investment plus you know net exports or
something like that so there's that
comment was just to separate those that
we're not thinking about 70s monetary
policy which is an area of economics
that is economics and I completely agree
about law I'm not a lawyer I think this
is basically just presenting you know
what we see from from the economists
point of view yeah which basically
allowed the original set of people who
bought from their ico to get 90% back
the value fell below
so what like what like how it worked and
it was successful or I have to look at
it more deeply oh yeah
all right thank you so there's no
reception starting now